-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
Incoming New York governor
Kathy Hochul
appeared this morning
on the "Today" show,
and so did Cuomo.
[ Laughter ]
The White House
announced yesterday
that the Biden
administration will send
more than 800,000 doses of
the Pfizer coronavirus vaccine
to Caribbean countries.
Not on purpose --
Ron DeSantis just keeps
chucking 'em into the ocean.
Officials in Philadelphia
announced a new mask mandate
yesterday due to rising
coronavirus cases,
which is going to be tricky
for any Philly residents
who have no discernible mouth
and only one huge nostril.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon opened a new
billion-dollar air hub
in Kentucky yesterday
that will serve as the central
location for Amazon Air.
Coincidentally, Amazon Air
is also what makes up
most of their packages.
In a new interview -- a new
interview, Rudy Giuliani said
that disgraced New York governor
Andrew Cuomo
will "resurrect himself
in some way."
And I'd take Rudy's word for it,
because it looks like
he was just resurrected.
Rock band Maroon 5
announced yesterday
that attendees
of their upcoming Ohio concert
must show proof of vaccination
or a recent negative
coronavirus test,
because they need to make sure
nothing bad happens to Maroon 4.
I mean, they're
not for everyone,
but some people love Maroon 3
and want to keep them safe.
There's just something special
about Maroon 2.
Oh, my God! Run, Adam!
Today was National
Middle Child Day,
but don't worry if you forgot.
Everyone did.
[ Laughter ]
Astronauts aboard
the International Space Station
recently held their own version
of the Olympics,
and it really spooked
the dressage horse.
[ Laughter ]